ما يقرب من 200 دوله مشاركه في قمه المناخ
في شرم الشيخ لكل منها جناح يبلغ عدد
متفاوت من الامطار ويبقى الرهان على
المسجد بين الديكور والصور والالوان في
لفت الانتباه وعكس ثقافه وحضاره كل بلد
وما يطرحه من رؤيه حول ازمات التغير
المناخي وتحديات تجاوزه
على اللون الاخضر هو اللون الاشجار
والغابات التي تزرع المانجو الصور ترمز
لثراء الطبيعه في نيجيريا
الجغرافيا لدينا بلدنا في امريكا الجنوبيه
حيث البحار والجبال والثلوج
امريكا ولكن يبقى الجناح الاوكراني فريدا
فالواقع وصوره وديكوراته عكست حجم الدماره
البيئيه الذي تعيشه بسبب الحرب
اشجار نقتلعت من جذورها وصور وارقام تجسد
حجم الخسائر التي طالت الارض التي كانت
تصنف بسله العالم من القمح
وحجمه الخسائر في الماشيه التي تنتج
اطنانا من الغذاء
القائمون على الجناح اكدوا ان الديكور نجح
في لفت الانظار وعكس الرساله الاوكرانيه
للمشاركين في القمه
من حجم الدمار الخسائر والاضرار البيئيه
كبيره وهذا ما حاولنا ايصاله من خلال هذا
الجناح ولان قمه المناخ تسعى لتوحيد
الجهود لمواجهه التحديات التي تواجه كوكب
الارض بعيدا عن السياسه عملت كل دوله على
عرض رسالتها في جناحها من خلال ديكورات
وصور معبره للفت الانظار اليها احمد عثمان
العربيه شرم الشيخ